I think it's it's hard when we see
someone like Yvette and console a
sitting up at this this table here to
see this kind of power and to see this
kind of strength and and resilience to
also remember the many of those of
escape a who are back living in their
villages next to the killers of their
own family and to remember what they're
actually living on a database database
Asst obviously I'm not Rwandan yet but
having worked in Rwanda over the last
decade it's it's strange how time flies
because it was just just a little over a
decade that I was sitting here in these
chairs at the University and I had no
idea that graduating and then deciding
to go off to Rwanda to work on an on a
short film would result in in the next
decade of my life being absorbed in this
history so I should say that everything
I learned really came first from these
chairs and and and some of the
individuals in this room who shared with
me particularly even at the Fortran on
video archives for Holocaust testimonies
here at Gail the power and the
importance of testimony and what we can
learn from testimony and the imperative
to record and and preserve testimony and
so I stand here really as a conduit of
those testimonies and so I want to keep
my words short and before I continue on
actually share a segment from these
testimonies of somebody who is back in
the countryside in Rwanda and and share
with you some of her thoughts and words
on what the legacy of the genocide
against the Tutsi in Rwanda actually is
in her own life I'll start with with on
Cielo
and if I may ask is it possible to turn
the lights out thank you
I'll try that again here we go
we can turn the lights back
I just show this I wanted to begin by
showing this particular clip from on
Sheila's testimony because I think that
even in as she recounts her memories and
her failing memory it's it's an ironic
moment in her life where her memory is
actually failing but she still feels the
imperative that she must continue to
remember even the names of her child and
she knows she's forgetting their names
and so she lives with this piece of
paper in her purse and she folds it up
every day and looks at it in order to
try to remember the names and and the
loss of her memory isn't just due to due
to age she's not very very old she's
still in her 50s and I share that
because I think that we often forget
that the genocide continues for the
vestkapp a that it's not something that
ended in 1994 after three months that it
continues every single day and in fact
as many academics often write genocides
have many different stages in the final
stage is the denial the elimination of
the evidence is the elimination of the
trace of the toss of the trace the bones
the history and so in the first panel we
talked a lot about prevention of
genocides and stopping genocides and
atrocities around the world and I think
that we often forget that the very act
of recording testimony or establishing
the truth establishing the history that
happened is an attempt to halt or halt
the perpetual genocide from continuing
and it is a constant act that we must
continue to engage in and even this very
commemoration this very memorialization
today is an act to attempt to stop all
of the doc denialists and and to stop
the the revision of the genocide that is
still taking place until it ends with
the elimination of the trace I'll leave
you with one story also of one of the
legacies of the 1994 genocide against
the
you'd see in Rwanda that I am very very
disturbed by when I'm back in Rwanda and
I just returned two weeks ago and I'm
astounded yes by much of the amazing
progress of the country and much of the
focus on building of roads and
infrastructure and certainly new traffic
lights and street signs which is you
know which is has been one of the
focuses of the country it's actually
quite quite exciting and interesting to
see that particular focus among many
others but the very unsettling sort of
reality of sitting down with others like
me who have come from the outside to
work in Rwanda as a result or as on
account of or because of because of this
history and then to share with me the
work that they're currently doing in
Rwanda and one of the organizations that
I I met somebody working at the
organization's gives micro loans and we
think this is amazing you know we have
people like us here in the United States
sending small loans to Rwanda by way of
PayPal to help somebody buy a cow and
maybe start a business and maybe have
some more income in their homes so that
they can pull themselves out of poverty
particularly if you know they're
suffering medical problems and need
extra money to go to the hospital and so
one of these micro loan organizations I
asked them I said do you have a specific
profile for that escapade and they said
well no we don't we don't discriminate
and I was puzzled okay here here we are
working in Rwanda because of this
genocide and the very individuals who
suffered the most are not being served
necessarily so I say okay well what does
that mean that she said well actually we
even have profiles for perpetrators I
said really could you tell me a little
bit more about she's well under our
model the way that we grant loans we
have to ensure that the loans are paid
back to the people who who grant the
loans so people in the United States who
send $20 we want to make sure that they
get their $20 back so they reinvested
again and you know actually a way that
we ensure that those loans are going to
be paid back as we make sure that there
are people in the circle around them who
can ensure that they will contribute and
she said in perpetrators have relatives
and larger families around them
and I was struck that here are
perpetrators being rewarded by the
international community by NGOs and
organizations that are striving to help
rebuild a country and we look back to
what Yvette just spoke about operation
turqoise in the zone that was opened up
and then the international community
that rushed to the aid of so many of
whom were perpetrators as genocidaires
carrying weapons in the so-called
refugee camps that were set up in the
Congo and remember our relationship to
these places and how we impact them so I
leave you with that at this moment and
then I think we can continue later on